after watching this video you should be
prepared to explain why the human
tendency to daydream
can be interrupted using a storytelling
marketing approach
to list three key benefits of
storytelling when it comes to consumer
engagement
to realize that different consumers are
looking for different relationships with
your company
and to explain the difference between
storytelling and story sharing
let's begin lesson one why storytelling
is essential
in social marketing when we think about
the way that our company or our brand
or our organization is represented to
the world it's easy for us to be focused
in on things like quality and
credibility and whether or not someone
wants to buy from us
but it's also important to understand
that for a lot of consumers
the very idea of who you are is also
important it's not always just enough
for people to know the name of your
company or product
they're interested in understanding what
the story is
behind your brand and that might be
something like how you came to be or why
you exist or what your mission is
or it might be something about the
personality and sort of the lifestyle
that's represented by your individual
company
now the storytelling movement has been
an area that we've really seen a lot of
growth
and a lot of improvement in the last
several years in social media with more
and more brands
moving towards this idea of sort of
humanizing their companies
by telling the stories that come out of
the company itself
out of the use of the product or even
out of the consumer stories
that you know share how products benefit
their lives or again just
what goes on in that interaction and
that dynamic between the organization
and between the customer side of things
now when it comes to storytelling
there's several different ways
in which this approach offers value to a
business and one of the key ones is on
the
emotional side we've talked a lot in the
social sharing dynamic in some of the
other areas of
you know the the spread and the viral
concept about how emotion is one of the
most
powerful things that impacts people's
decision-making and engagement with the
brand
so when it comes to creating that
emotional connection
or leaving people with some type of
emotional response storytelling is one
of the most powerful ways to
impact that it gives you an opportunity
to sway the emotion of consumers
in terms of how they look at or view or
are receptive to your brand
now another thing that storytelling can
really do that adds a lot of value
is the idea of making you credible
because a lot of times the way we tell
stories especially when we're
incorporating in
true to life examples or you know
consumer stories
there's an implied credibility that
comes through that storytelling and
comes through those third-party
experiences
that can help people feel more secure
about doing business with you
not just more emotionally positive but
actually feel that security of trusting
that
what they think they're going to get or
what they're hoping to get
that there's going to be enough follow
through and enough other people have had
a positive experience
for them to really trust that that's
what's going to happen now another area
that
storytelling brings a lot of value into
a company is the in the idea of making
you
memorable because human beings are
wired for stories we are much more
capable of recalling
broad ideas and concepts and emotions
when they're communicated via a story so
if we give someone
a list of facts a list of selling points
you know
a list of reasons why to do business
with you the ones that touch them
emotionally
or that you know problem solved those
tend to stick with them but a lot of the
data
gets lost but when we put it in the
format of a story and someone is sharing
what their
experience was our brains literally
archive it and categorize it differently
and our recall level goes up so again
along with building trust and along with
creating that that emotional
impact the fact that people are better
able to recall
the information that's communicated to
them via that story
helps make it a very powerful marketing
tool now in addition to that it's
important to keep in mind
that on average people tend to be
daydreamers in fact study after study
shows that if our minds aren't occupied
with an important task if we're not
truly focused on something we tend to
drift off
and when we look at that concept of
daydreaming the average human
spends literally half of their waking
hours
daydreaming we average 2 000 waking
drifts
per day with an average length of about
14 seconds
so you do the math on that 2 000 times
times 14 seconds
that's a pretty good portion of our day
where our brain is drifting off
but when they look at the brain's
ability to stay focused versus having
those
drips we stay focused during a story if
we're reading a book
if we're watching a movie if someone is
telling us an
engaging story we are better equipped
and better able
to put those drifts off and really stay
focused on what's happening
so that's one of the other sort of
scientific and
concrete reasons why that memorable
factor comes into play when we present
things via stories
now stories also allow us to connect in
one of the easiest ways possible
again because our brain is going to be a
little more focused on being able to
receive that message
so by using stories to spread your brand
message
or to explain your offerings or to
demonstrate how they work
you increase the chance of keeping your
audience focused on you
and giving them enough recall that they
can come back at a later point
to actually do some business with you
now think of storytelling
from sort of the mindset of how we meet
and engage with other people
so in general when we're meeting up with
a prospective friend or a job prospect
maybe we're coming for an interview
a service workers even just a stranger
on the street
any conversation that goes past just
hello how are you doing and the cursory
you know kind of polite responses it
tends to be a story
this is what we do when we meet we're
naturally wired to seek out
insight and common ground and
information
about who another person is and in those
interpersonal relationships the types of
questions we
ask you know the words we use they're
indicative of the type of relationship
we want to build
so clearly if you know if you're single
and you see someone else that
you know you hope might be single that
might be one of the early questions you
ask and then based on whether
you know there's a romantic interest
there you're probably going to ask
different questions than if it's a
interview prospect for a job or if
you're meeting up with a
you know co-worker for the first time
the relationship that we're looking for
denotes the type of information we want
and that's one of the important things
for us to keep in mind
when it comes to storytelling is we also
have the ability to tailor our story to
the audience
so we can put those different features
up front we can weave them in
in a different way if we're appealing to
a group
of 60-something females that love to sew
versus a group of 20-something
millennials that
love whiskey tasting it's a different
message that gets put together with
different focuses and features
there's also different things that we're
going to put forward if we're proposing
you know a million dollar contract
versus a 25
impulse buy that someone can you know
click and order online and have
delivered the next day
now on the business side of this we need
to think about
what the story that we need is because a
lot of times
we get so focused in business on getting
the conversion
that we forget that sometimes part of
getting that conversion
is creating those emotions building that
credibility and trust you know helping
them have exposure to what's possible
and for a long time this has been done
through education we might put up videos
or articles
that aim to educate and to demonstrate
the story side of it
brings that more social interaction and
environment into the mix and that's
something important for us to keep in
mind
so a quote that i really love about this
concept that sort of
lays the foundation of why it's so
important comes from the chief content
officer over at digitas
and he says the challenge is clear by
now intrusive interruptive
self-centered marketing no longer works
the way it once did
and its effectiveness will only continue
to diminish in the social age
because again the way that we share
information back and forth with each
other and the ways that
messages spread it happens differently
in the social media age than it did
before when
it was more advertising focused and
where marketing really was more about
you know pushing the advertise pushing
the message and sort of the don draper
style of you know
if you don't like the conversation
change the conversation and tell people
what you want them to hear
because so much marketing is now driven
by consumers through that conversation
we need to be able to approach it in a
different way
now another side of that is the idea
there's a difference between
storytelling
and story sharing and some of it boils
down to semantics but some of it
also does need to be kind of taken into
account when we look at how we might put
our message together
because semantically consider the
difference between telling and sharing
so to tell is to communicate information
facts or news to someone in spoken or
written word
it's to order instruct or advise someone
to do something
that second part that i want you to keep
in mind but to share
is to give a portion of something to
another to tell someone about
something especially something personal
it's a
again it's a slight semantic difference
but it's a huge difference in terms of
our approach
and i love this seth godin quote that
really pairs up with that idea
the best part of show and tell has never
been the telling part it's been the
showing
letting someone see an experience and
inviting them into that shared
experience
and that's one of those things that
makes the social version
of storytelling really more like story
sharing
especially if you want to do it in a way
that creates that back and forth
consumer engagement
story telling in its traditional sense
is more the stories that we've put into
commercials and advertising
and there's a place for that there's a
place to put that together in the social
realm and it's very
important but the other area that that
we're just starting to kind of merge
into and that really needs some
exploration by brands is that idea of
the social sharing where it really is
about
engaging back and forth with your
audience and inviting them to be part of
an experience
with you and with your brand so ask
yourself
do you want to tell your story to people
or do you want to share it with them
and let them share their story with you
and how do you meld those two together
and what does that look like
within your particular company or among
your target audio
so now that we've laid the foundation of
why storytelling is so important
and sort of what type of impact it can
have the next thing we need to do
is look at the business side of telling
your story what does it look like to
create a narrative or something that's
representative of either
your business's story or sort of the
lifestyle or concept or ideas that you
want to
promote to people now there's tons of
questions you could ask yourself
to start building your story but we can
focus in
on a couple key areas as a starting
point
to build from one of the first ones is
the idea
of whether or not you have a founder
story now for a lot of
brands the story of their founder is so
interesting or inspiring that it catches
the eye and it makes people take a
second look at the product
so think of the companies that are sort
of iconic in terms of
who their their founder or their leader
is so whether that was
steve jobs and the role he played at
apple or walt disney and the inspiration
and the role he brought
to you know the entire disney complex or
loads and loads of other businesses
there are lots of examples out there
of how the brand itself was so tied
to the person who was sort of leading
the helm that that became part of their
story and people were really
interested in it now we can find loads
of examples
of different brands where the founder
really plays a critical role
in representing who they are now great
example of this
is spanx the founder sarah blakely has
really embraced the story
both of how she came up with the idea
which was basically she was trying to
fit into a pair of cream pants for a
party and they didn't fit quite right
and she knew that when she put her
pantyhose on
everything seemed to lay nicer so she
literally cut the feet out of a pair of
pantyhose
and put them on and that's what launched
the brand you know she loves to
sort of tell that story but she also
loves to
tell the story you know from her tagline
of putting her own butt on the line
pays off because the way that she made
her first sale to neiman marcus
is that she literally dragged the buyer
into a dressing room
and she went in and she put on a pair of
white pants and came out
and said you know here's what i look
like without them and went back in and
put her pair of spanx on
under the white pants and came back out
and said now here's what happens when
i'm wearing these
and the buyer from neiman marcus ended
up placing a huge order and it was the
first
major sale that she got that put her in
place somewhere
so those stories and sort of the yeah
this is how it happened you know
this is literally what a difference it
makes that becomes part of
the brand and sort of sarah blakely's
journey as an entrepreneur and you know
moving her way up into the you know the
forbes list
of uh you know highest earning females
in the united states
all of that plays a huge role in how
they promote the brand itself
and in sort of the the storyline and the
lifestyle line that they want to promote
to the people
that might buy the product
now on a completely differently themed
vein
we have fast food chain wendy's in the
us and canada
where dave thomas was the founder and
even though he's
you know he passed away several years
ago he's still
a critical part of the brand and of the
story
because basically it was the idea that a
working class guy makes good
and continues to act like a
working-class guy while building a
massive charity
because it wasn't uncommon even when he
was ceo
to see him show up in a store somewhere
and start working behind the counter or
sweeping the floor somewhere
he always played that role that made it
clear to his employees
that he wasn't above them that he was
one of them and part of them
and has a huge huge ongoing charity
effort
for adoption because he was adopted as a
child and so
all of that plays into the narrative of
wendy's
and who they are and what their brand
message is and
and the lifestyle that they want to
promote to
customers in fact if you if you go there
now and
you buy a meal and you get your cup all
of the cups have stories
of kids when they were finally adopted
and what it meant to them when they were
adopted or you know what their first
experience was
having a new family so again that plays
into the story
just because people are interested in
the start of where how it came to be
so looking at you know what the stories
are from within your team and it doesn't
always have to be
that founder story sometimes it's just
someone who works there
post cereal paired up with burns group
and
use real factory workers to create a
round of honey bunches of oats
commercials and let's
let's take a quick look at what one of
those actually look like so you can kind
of see the storytelling in action here
i get out of work and i go to the store
and somebody's smelling around i smell
cookies
i say oh no you just smell me i just got
out of work that's honey bunches old
that's all i said don't eat me now
[Music]
now there's short simple easy stories
there's nothing complex to them they
more just make you smile and laugh
but they're the types of stories that
come from listening to the people
who work at your company from thinking
about how your company and their
experience
impacts the world around them
now another question that we can look at
is does your company or group
solve a problem now this isn't about the
reasons you think you're great or the
reason you think people should buy from
you
it's about that unique way that you
solve an
issue that consumers or on the b2b side
of things you know that
the buying agent is looking at that
they're trying to fix
now a great example of this is airbnb or
you could look at
uber or lyft on a similar vein allowing
people to experience
travel in a new and affordable way but
also letting you know owners or drivers
earn extra money you know from something
that might have been sitting there
empty anyways you know that idea that
when you're traveling you don't have to
stay
in a bland expensive hotel in fact when
i travel for business pretty much any
place i go
i always book via airbnb because you
know if i can have
a bedroom and a living room and a
kitchen especially for traveling as a
family
and there can be you know separate
bedrooms as opposed to having my kids
all stay in the same room with my
husband and i
it just makes sense but there's also the
story side of that
of its different experiences and that's
one of the big things that people talk
about is how the experience
changes and even on the side of trying
to recruit people to put their
properties
it becomes about the freedom and the
lifestyle that's enabled
and there's tons of examples on youtube
of people sharing
how you know leasing out that you know
their vacation property
the rest of the year when they're not
there you know pays for the vacation
property and more
or you know the people who now travel
full-time because they're able to lease
out you know their apartment or their
home or something else
on airbnb the story side comes
from the problems that are solved for
people
now another great example of a company
that focuses on their story from that
side is dollar shave club
they basically took a problem everyone
complains about and they made it go away
you know the idea that razors cost are
ridiculous
amount of money that you always forget
to buy new ones until it's too late so
you're shaving with a dull
blazer and it's just inconvenient so all
of their messaging focuses in
on that idea of we make it cheap we make
it easy
and you know it shows up right at your
house and you don't ever have to think
about it anymore
and their commercials all tell the same
story with kind of a
you know funny modern millennial focused
way so let's take a
look at one of those as an example as a
founder of my own club
i'd love to know how does yours work
dollar shave club presents
what the fact it's simple you choose
from one of our three great razors we'll
give you a free reusable handle
and each month we'll send you
replacement cartridges for just a few
bucks
that means you get to shave with the
fresh blood anytime you want which feels
amazing why be locked into a contract
no we wouldn't lock you into anything
that's a relief
how long for delivery i've got a
conjugal visit next week
well what if i don't have to shave that
often
no problem after you sign up you can
choose to get replacement cartridges
every other month
you sound like my mom i like that
ew what's this i hear about dollar shave
club selling more than just razors
you heard right we make all our own high
quality grooming products like dr cover
shave butter
boogies hair gel and big cloud daily
face moisturizer with sunscreen
now you know what the fact is up with
dollar shave club so join the club today
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here